in our discussions of the 2018 midterm
elections we have talked about voter
suppression in general but we've also
talked about the specific situation in
Georgia and Georgia has the center
interesting interesting it's probably
more outrageous would be would be a
better word outrageous situation where
the Secretary of State Brian Kemp who's
a Republican and is responsible for
influencing such decisions as those
about purging voters those about voting
hours and voting locations he happens to
be running in the race that he is also
regulating from his perspective as
Secretary of State he's the Republican
nominee for governor in Georgia against
Democrat Stacey Abrams he is the
Secretary of State and the Republican
candidate for governor and we've been
covering his extremely heavy-handed
voter suppression tactics this includes
taking away polling places strategically
from black areas poor areas and
democratic areas causing confusion and
vote abandonment when you plan to vote
in a certain place and then you either
hear that it's not going to be open or
it might not be open or you show up and
it's not open he's suspended more than
53,000 voter registrations 70% of those
for black people for violating what's
called the exact match standard which
says that your voter registration and
needs to be in the exact same name as
the ID or document that you use when you
show up or and/or to get registered and
as we know there can be situations with
people's middle names hyphenation of
last names all sorts of reasons why
there could be slight differences he
purged more than a hundred and seven
thousand voters from the voter rolls for
not voting last election and he has been
sued for leaving more than six million
voting records open to hacking also
interestingly back in 2016 there was
help offered by homeland security to
secure the 2016 election he's the only
secretary of state in the country who
rejected that help so this is a guy with
a history
of suppressing the vote and now he has
admitted during an event at a place
called the Blind Pig parlour bar in
Atlanta for an event called Georgia
professionals for Kemp he admitted that
he's concerned that people might
exercise their right to vote and he
acknowledges that people exercising
their right to vote wouldn't be good for
him but it would be good for his
Democratic opponent Stacey Abrams this
is not about illegal votes this is not
about voter fraud that he's concerned
about he's just concerned about turnout
he's concerned that people will vote
here's the audio from the event we were
literally there a lot of that with
absentee ballot requests they have
unprecedented number of that which is
something that continues to concern us
especially at her bite uses an exercise
very right to vote which they absolutely
can if people exercise their right to
vote we're in trouble
this is panic in the Kemp campaign vote
suppressor in chief admits he's worried
about voter turnout do we need any more
dots to connect at this point his
campaign was asked for comment about his
comments at this event that were
recorded they have said no no comment
the Facebook event page for this event
has been retro actively deleted this is
a strategy and that's the thing Pat he's
not saying anything we didn't know right
we know that the right C's suppressing
votes as a strategy for winning
elections we know they know when voter
turnout is higher that tends to help the
more progressive candidate the candidate
that's more to the left left the thing
is this has been the subtext right like
the subtext for closing polling
locations and D registering people and
purging voters the subtext has been we
don't want people to vote now he's in a
recording actually saying that he's
making it the headline this reminded me
of the MIT Romney 47% video
one because it's audio-only also you
know you hear the dishes clanging in the
background but he's willing to say those
things in front of his supporters maybe
like a rich donor base but not willing
to say it to the general public and you
know everyone has a camera phone
nowadays that stuff can get out and most
importantly it's not really a secret
it's like the worst kept secret in
Republican political strategy and
there's nothing less American than just
being concerned about people exercising
their right to vote
the response is likely going to be
straight out of the Trump playbook which
is weighted out it hopefully will blow
over do nothing and that's why I'm
telling you as I told you yesterday day
before you can vote now early voting is
happening now please vote in this race
if you vote in Georgia with the last
poll from October 21st and 22nd has this
race as 48:48 there is a possibility of
a Democratic governor in Georgia this
would be a massive victory now if you go
back to the prior polls back from like
October 15th the seventeenth one had
Stacey Abrams up one had camp up it's
close that's the point the margin of
error definitely afraid this is winnable
this is winnable is the point if they
know it they're worried they're running
scared please vote please vote today's
show was made possible in part by Scion
Games and their new game for phone and
tablet called antidote which is an award
winning strategy game it's all about
using vaccines to defend the human body
from bacteria and viruses it's fast
paced the graphics are amazing the game
has actually been commended by the World
Health Organization because it has a
mission to fight back against the anti
vaccine misinformation so the game is
educational and fun to play download
antidote for free on your phone or
tablet in the Google Play Store or the
iOS App Store and have a blast using
vaccines and the body's immune system to
fight off
deadly diseases and don't forget to
search for scion games on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram if you're
watching this on YouTube I've put the
links under the video